TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, everyone.
We're now in the Design
Sandbox, and I've got Liam here,
who is a design advocate.
He's going to tell us
all about the latest
features and announcement
for material design.
In fact, there's
some tools that we're
going to take a look at, right?
LIAM SPRADLIN: Yeah, absolutely.
So one of our big
announcements was
the idea of material
theming, and that's
really embodied not
only in the new guidance
but also in some new
tools that we have,
one of them being
the Theme Editor,
which is part of
our Sketch plugin.
So I just want to do
a quick demo here.
You can see we have four
existing mock-ups on screen,
and we have a theme
set up in Theme Editor.
So if we switch
over to that, you
can do something as easy as
just adjusting the color.
So if you choose a blue color,
or you can choose a default
material swatch, it
will automatically
generate a tonal
palette from that
and apply it to all
of our components,
tuned for accessibility
and style.
So then we can choose
an accent color.
I'll do a yellow.
And then we'll just save that.
And when we switch over
here, it will show us
a library is available.
So we just update our
symbols, and all of our colors
have been systematically applied
throughout all of our mock-ups.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
I think particularly is this
idea of the color cascading
through your whole design when
you just make a simple change.
LIAM SPRADLIN: Right.
So it's not just
taking one color
and applying that
everything in the interface.
It's actually drawing
from this tonal palette
to say, what is the
best shade for a text
field in its resting state?
Or what should
the text label be?
So it tunes that for
accessibility and for style.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And can you
show us one more thing--
exporting this into Gallery?
LIAM SPRADLIN: Yeah, absolutely.
So part of our
Sketch plugin is also
the ability to upload
everything to Gallery,
so I can just upload
this as a new iteration
on our existing
[? crane ?] project.
And once it uploads,
there we go.
You can just hit View,
and in Gallery it's
uploaded all of our mocks.
And because we used Theme
Editor, when you enter Inspect
Mode, you can actually
click on things
and find what the text style is
and all of the different specs
that you'll need to
actually implement this.
So you can select like
something like a [INAUDIBLE],,
and that will actually
give you links
out to both the materials
spec and the platform-specific
implementation.
So you can switch to Android
if you're working on Android,
and then click out and be
taken right to documentation
for that component.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really awesome.
Thank you so much for
showing that to us.
LIAM SPRADLIN: Yeah.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
And if you'd like
to find out more about
material design and all
the announcements
from here at I/O,
head on over to material.io.